[Music]
in the wake of Captain Marvel that
Disney have just released another
trailer for Avengers and game and
there's a lot to impacto MIT throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the trailer as well as what the things
in it could lead to this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
know any of their theories in Avengers
and game and then I highly recommend
that you turn off now
with that out the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I explain
it so you don't have to okay so the
trailer opens with a pretty substantial
recap of the last 10 years in the MCU as
well as what the events have led up to
we get Tony Stark recounting his life
and how important that pepper is to him
and see him stranded in space with
little hope of rescue he says it seems
like a thousand years ago that he became
Iron Man and it really does as we get
flashbacks this ties into the next part
in which we hear Peggy Carr are saying
the world has changed and none of us can
go back sometimes the best that we can
do is to start over
this of course ties into the fan theory
that the Avengers will indeed be
traveling through time in order to take
the Infinity stones from Thanos and that
Steve will remain in the 40s so he can
live out the life that he would have had
with Peggy if he'd not been frozen it's
clear that New York and the world have
been decimated and we see Hawkeye
training with what appears to be his
daughter many have theorized that she
was killed with the rest of his family
during the snap so perhaps this is a
flashback that becomes the reason why he
is now the ronin which we also see in
the trailer we then get more flashbacks
before we see ant-man staring at missing
posters obviously when he was in the
quantum realm
during the snap missed everyone
disappearing so he's having to catch you
up the hard way Hawkeye and black widow
2 are reunited in the trailer and it's
clear that their friendship is stronger
than ever
Hawkeye appears to be going on missions
and keeping the law so it's good to see
them be united we then see the rest of
the team building up to the mission and
staying whatever it
before we get shots of the quantum suits
these of course have been leaked in
merchandise such as toys and it's great
to see them in the fall film many have
theorized that the heroes will be using
these to travel through time and space
and this design confirms it Tony is also
shown in this part so we can confirm
that he go home with nebula who too is
present we also end with Thor meeting
Captain Marvel stating that he likes her
and whilst white men may not at least
the god of thunder does I think it's
pretty clear that they will definitely
be going back to things like the Battle
of New York Ultron and more to get the
Infinity stones and destroy them in the
past so Dan ass cannot carry out the
snap of course I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it and if there's anything I
missed make sure to let me know in the
comments if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of Captain Marvel which
would be linked at the end of this video
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]